[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want what do you guys want
to talk about
we were just talking about busting nuts
classic what's the best nut you ever
busted you know what i'm saying yeah
that's the first one bro you've been
chasing that dragon ever since
yeah yeah really i think
it it got better with age
yourself off i'm shooting blanks bro
when you're when you're young and you
just start jacking off
you're heaving and hovering and
nothing's coming out the first time you
did you bust and you're like what the
[ __ ] was that yeah
what was that yeah and then you feel all
weird and guilty afterwards
you're like but you got to do it again
and see if you feel the same way but you
were like
what just came out what the [ __ ]
was that i straight up thought i
discovered something that man had not
found yet
first time i nutted i did this i was
like oh my god you wanted to put it back
in i thought
i peed on myself i did too i thought i
pissed myself i thought
and i i ran to the bathroom embarrassed
yeah i was half asleep it was like a wet
dream
it was i was like half asleep half a
week and i was probably like
and i was like oh and i was like oh [ __ ]
i just pissed myself yeah then you're
like
that's not pissed what is that wait were
you doing it during your
you're sleeping or you're just trying to
i was like half asleep i don't know i
think i was like
there had to be some pressure there
somewhere but i don't think i was just
jerking off i think i was like
maybe just dry humping my my bed like
you slowly
get into you don't even know what you're
doing you guys get wet dreams i've never
had a wedding bro
you wish i had it first one was like the
hat in between
obviously if you pee on yourself you
don't wake up right so yeah
that kind of feeling there was this uh
late night japanese tv show that i was
watching
um in japan okay yeah and uh they were
they were teaching you how to perfect
the best wet dream
yo and if this guy was giving i tried it
but i mean well okay so what you got to
do
is like he jacks off up until the point
of climax and he goes straight to sleep
wow and he says that
does he pass then bus no he doesn't bust
he holds it at the peak the edges
that's exactly what they said on the tv
show everyone was like wow you're so
disciplined right contract sex no
yeah and he went to sleep and he did a
tutorial on it and he [ __ ]
busted a nut in the middle of the night
and everyone was like oh my god
so i i tried it but then i ended up just
coming because i was like can't hold it
you can't i was an undisciplined child
you try to get that nut dude
by the way this is [ __ ] regular
japanese tv at night
that they were [ __ ] showing this
thing at and i [ __ ] i couldn't do it
dude and i
i think that until this day i don't have
the discipline
to not bust and go to sleep try it
tonight i bet you'll find i know i like
to go
you you're dead i think it's in our it's
on our it's impossible if we're getting
to the point where you're about to bust
yeah you gotta stop gotta go have you
guys heard about
tantric sex you don't you have sex but
you don't bust
what does that mean yeah yeah so you use
a breath of fire sounds lame bro
what's a breath of fire it's like this
whole thing it's tantric sex and then
you kind of like when you're about to
come you kind of suck the energy
in through your kind of like and you
come through your back
and then up the spine and then you kind
of come you crown
or some [ __ ] your head shocker and then
you kind of like
[ __ ] come into the universe don't
pretend like you don't know the
specifics and the [ __ ] you haven't
memorized the bible and you do this like
every other week
when we were younger we studied a little
bit it's so [ __ ] weird wait so when
you did that
you didn't nothing came out of your
penis no no i i didn't master it
was it worth it yeah i've had some
moments where i think i kind of
got a little bit of it going this is the
[ __ ] you're crowned and calm down
no coming so the sting does this [ __ ]
right yes sting bro
i just talked about this recently so my
dude this comedian guy just died paul
mooney you know paul
oh yeah rest and peace man one of the
best
legends so check this out back in the
day he has two twin sons
he has his twin sons that's four sons
that's some twin sons and i forget their
names but they're paul mooney sons and
their comedians and when we're doing the
poetry and the comedy world all together
they became friends anyway they're the
one putting me and my brothers on the
tantric sex they
came in our house one time with these
videotapes we're all watching the
videotapes taser explaining like tantric
sex to us on some [ __ ]
[ __ ] the moody twins bhs
brothers brought vhs over to explain to
you they basically
evangelized you into tantric sex me and
my brothers yeah the moony twins
but you never knew how to do it the
right way no they we watched the vhs
tips
but you have to practice it right yeah
then him and his brother in the movie
twist he hasn't got that part yet
but it's like you gotta do the breath of
fire
did they do it to you no we were just
like it was kind of funny because comedy
and [ __ ] we were just talking about like
this is the real [ __ ] that sting was
doing and [ __ ] we were trying to like
all right we was on this do you have the
discipline to do the tantric sex
and not come and just like leave i was
not a master at the situation
that's a master level the benefits of
tantric stuff so the it's
all here is downside so yeah the
supposedly the orgasm is like
10 20 fold of a regular organ how does
that even happen
i mean they say the tape was saying you
know practice because you could hurt
yourself
then you hurt yourself of course you
hurt yourself
it's a shocker like a toad cramp and
it's a law it's a law and it's a long
sex section
session too it's like it's like hours
like you're supposed to it's like a
part-time job yeah like you're there
having sex for [ __ ] hours see that's
the thing how long
what is the the most optimal time
duration for sex in your opinion
30 seconds but it depends on depends on
how much penetration hands on the
situation you can't be [ __ ] in an
alley for three hours
no no 30 seconds in the [ __ ] alley
you get bust your nut right now you at
home
and you've got the flowers you had the
great danny of the wine you need to let
that [ __ ] go at least 20 you need to be
a lot of foreplay
yeah a lot foreplay get the lingerie
mouth working a lot of mouth working
yeah
let that dick rest let you like catch a
little vibe in the middle of the
restaurant and like damn i'm going to
fight let's go and hit that bathroom
[ __ ] quick in the bathroom of course i
never have that
you never had the [ __ ] quick thing i
don't [ __ ] yeah i don't [ __ ] public
areas either
do you guys ever [ __ ] cars like on
road trips i have
but it's not it's so uncomfortable i'm
such a big tall too yeah
you need to get a suburban or something
you need to get an rv i need that
[ __ ] excursion or something
yeah pulled all the seats down you
didn't want them american semi truck
a big american car got that big bench
seat in the front
i know you can't be going around a mini
cooper trying to [ __ ] there hell no
they are roomy i got to say i just
wrapped them a little bit they're pretty
roomy
don't tint anything though yeah you're
not [ __ ] in there though
no chance [ __ ] cars is very
uncomfortable it's really uncomfortable
that's why you're doing the back seat i
used to have a miata
oh no just doggy style the best position
that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] yeah you you know you can but
it's just
it's not optimal bro this is horrible
because it's like
you're sitting like this and then you're
trying to get your body into the reverse
l it just it's just a reverse l you're
like
you know when you're in the backseat you
still got to put like one leg like on
the floor and one leg knee on like a
chair yeah
i'm talking about it's a process yeah
you got to be like lindbergh you got to
like
it's a young man's game yeah yeah like
[ __ ] cars is a teenager you can
stretch outside and then get back in
it's not too bad
you get to a certain age like i'm never
going to [ __ ] in a car is that a
necessity
you don't you don't yeah if you could
have a bed where you could you know have
sex or whatever that's that's way better
that's the most ideal you know what i
can't do anymore is unshowered sex
same i don't know how i used to [ __ ]
without showering for days because you
live the good life now
and i think back and i'm all like how
did i get [ __ ]
without even showering first they were
so nice
yeah a lot of chicks talking [ __ ] about
you i bet being like oh the dirtiest
dick i ever did joe
you know i feel bad i do
i'm judging them why did they tell me to
go take a shower
that's how i feel you know why because
it was dirty as [ __ ] they thought the
horny for you
yeah that's true yeah but people imagine
that moment like all the way down
oh you should shower but they didn't
shower either exactly as a teenager you
just don't think about this [ __ ] it's so
weird dude don't be times where like you
go to a rave you come back to the
[ __ ] crash house you spend the night
for like a week together you probably
shower like one time throughout the
whole time
and then you [ __ ] like [ __ ]
awesome yeah but dude don't you guys
remember doing [ __ ] like that yeah
and then you're just like you're like a
traveling homeless man but you have
money and then you're cool
you're [ __ ] in the shower though yeah
well it's always what you're not in the
shower
just [ __ ] non-stop to get them like
like like you just rediscovered sex
with a new person like god damn we
[ __ ] like eight times a day like i
knew what the [ __ ] are we doing
dude shower sex is is tough too man
because water is
it's hitting me like [ __ ] here yeah
and like you know i gotta have the chick
in front of it basically
wait you're so tall that the shower is
hitting you're like
[ __ ] eyes you're doing some [ __ ] like
this you get your footing like that i'll
get that foot in real nice and it's not
like cramping and [ __ ]
you need some stability bro cause you
start slipping like who spilled the show
what the you need the right mat bro i
don't have one of my exes
stand against like the the bathtub area
just to get my dick in here because
it just wouldn't line up god no the line
yeah and water's not lubricant
yeah it waters it away yeah water the
jacuzzi it's always a good idea until he
starts popping off the jacuzzi
that's why jacuzzis are hand jobs only
yeah yeah it
sounds like a good idea but it's not a
good idea it's not it's only in the
movies bro
that one's that [ __ ] in the movie it's
just good yeah hands these shit's cool
like it's good
like oh a little sexy thing going on but
once you start it's not
like we need to get our bodies maybe get
started there and then dry yourself up
and make your way
that's that's usually what happens
anyway i am because you're
while you're doing you're like all right
brother this is this i come in the
movies they look so passionate and [ __ ]
and then they don't show the real [ __ ]
really [ __ ]
no this is dry and in the movies last
like 30 seconds
today's video is brought to you by hbo
max
did you know they got something brand
new and it's super cool and i knew it
was gonna happen soon
but i think they're doing it first where
they're gonna have
same day movie premieres on the
streaming platform which means if it's
coming out in theaters it's gonna come
out
on the app in your bedroom bathroom
living room wherever you watch movies on
the same day that's crazy so it's like
hey let's go to the theater
this movie's coming out you're like nah
i'mma stay home and watch it on my couch
baby
that's super freaking cool and it's no
additional charge to the subscriber it's
just
one extra thing that they're offering to
make movie watching
that much more accessible you know what
i'm excited to watch what those who wish
me dead
because angelina jolie one of my
favorite
most oh i wish one day i don't even care
if you're like 90 years old and you're a
senior citizen
i will still love you angelina jolie
please notice me
yeah i'm gonna watch and support that on
hbo max she is
never ever what's the word
she's always delicious very also we
gotta support the asians because
john chu is coming out with a new film
called in the heights
and you know he's the director of crazy
rich asians if you guys don't know and
i'm pretty excited to go ahead and check
out that film baby
so if you're excited to see brand new
releases every single month
go to hbom.ax
otr june to check this out sign up for
hbo max and get all kinds of new movies
all the time even the brand new ones
that are just dropping the same day in
the theaters go check it out
did you ever get caught [ __ ] like
pants or anybody or friends or anything
caught jacking off multiple times but
never [ __ ] never [ __ ]
in my mom's eyes i'm probably a big
loser
she's like my son's always checking off
he's always [ __ ] himself he's
bringing these girls over but never
[ __ ] um
he brings his girls over and he jacks
off for some reason now my dad
walked in the room one time but he was
cool enough to turn around and be like
hey what's up
you know i'm gonna let me just walk down
that's cool that was cool pop thanks pop
and i don't know i was on top i was
about to i don't know if i was
[ __ ] [ __ ] i wasn't like but i was
we were definitely how do you guys
do that in a big household with a bunch
of like
family members dude i lost my virginity
with all my brothers in the room
in the long run were they sleeping yeah
because so
we're in paramount damn what time is
this on patreon nope
nope yes
no so we me and my brothers in paramount
we lived in the
you know the um separate garage what's
the street name
it was called obispo one three six or
seven and a half business
once one 1367 abyssal but we're gone
that's gone but that's name of our crew
one three six or seven and a half
because it was our separate garage that
we converted into our room right
yeah but we all just you know the pool
table there with lockers we all but we
all live together like
four brothers and then sometimes my
cousins that stayed with us there was a
gang of us in the room
but no one had like beds and [ __ ] we
also used to sleep on the floor
then one cousin got a bed and then but
anyway when i lost my virginity
i met all the [ __ ] everybody
was in the room were they sleeping
yeah like everyone had different girls
and stuff and like we all kind of like
oh wait other
there was like a party but they weren't
i don't think anyone was just [ __ ]
but it's like i
you know you're just making nothing
hanging out and then all of a sudden
it's like oh it's going down it was like
a big
make-out party yeah i just pictured
a bunch of brothers trying to sleep
snoring and [ __ ] and then you're just
saying
i didn't look at my little boy he was
[ __ ] out to sleep and i was like this
dude is sleeping but you gotta be quiet
yeah get it in see what i'm saying
that's another thing too when you're
what like high school college or
whatever
at that age you know mad people are
partying and you're just
huddle there's like so many huddles like
in a room right like
you would go to get one vegas hotel room
and have like 20 people in there
whatever this is a normal thing right
and everyone was always
[ __ ] but quietly it's like a cuddle
well you don't know who's [ __ ] not
like
if you're in a hotel party right and
then like
you know some people might leave or
whatever some people just crash because
they're so high or whatever right
if you wake up at five in the morning
you're going to see some butt cheek
shaking true
quiet that's that age but i ain't an
orgy it ain't like no it's like
someone's [ __ ]
i remember i was okay so you know like
there's two queen beds right and then
there's like space in between
i was on the side where like the ac was
right that [ __ ] woke me up cause it was
sold out i had to go take a piss i get
up and as i'm walking in the two
like on the beds there's like people
just piled up sleeping but in the
two crevice right all i see is [ __ ]
butt cheeks humping on on other side and
i'm like
goddamn they're just humping their
mattresses
they're just on beat yeah two different
people humping their mattress with their
asses out
yeah like i can see that but they're not
even on the bed they're like on the side
of the bed
right where the little alleyways are
yeah to get to the more discreet you
know it is like weeks i'm just seeing
like
yeah yeah that's going squeak but that
grounds got a lot of
good support tested
battle tested that's crazy
mm-hmm you [ __ ] are you [ __ ] public
though you've done that
yeah but not like uh not in like
a restaurant bathroom or anything like
on the road or whatever i thought you
[ __ ] in a dog house
i did that was before geo's time that's
a big-ass dog house what the
[ __ ] it was like oh it's like high
school you know when you're like
ready and you just like talk about
you're just [ __ ] around oh it'd be
cool to [ __ ] here [ __ ] there and then i
think we're just walking down like the
town center
and we walked into like a big ass like
petsmart and then we saw one of those
for like an extra large dog like uh
saint bernard
like what if we [ __ ] in there and they
just sometimes like
fun talk turns into real [ __ ] yeah you
[ __ ] a petsmart
yeah you [ __ ] in a pet during school
yeah you're like 18 17 or something it's
a big-ass dog house
that's crazy [ __ ] in a dog it was also
like 130 though
she was 6-7 that's a goal weight that's
his goal
and you walk around town and you're
looking at all these places that you can
maybe [ __ ]
oh yeah with your next you're like damn
that's your conversations
aren't that deep that's a good place i
feel like i'm still doing that but
that's like dreaming
can i talk my girl into [ __ ] in that
dog house
if that's what i'm like just in the
future just like hey you know what bart
did
[Music]
but the thing about is you did it when
you were younger because we didn't have
our own spots in our own beds it's like
so like
i'm [ __ ] improving my own brothers i
gotta find other places to [ __ ] instead
of nothing is better than your mattress
after you guys took a shower and the ac
is perfect yes
it's like there's a perfect scenario
you're just like dude why would i do it
the other way
first world problems dude because i
always wondered that too i was like man
i was down a [ __ ]
everywhere but why am i so boring now
because i just want a
solid shower and a dope ass bed yeah now
nowadays like you know having sex like
in a controlled environment
where you know you're going to be where
it's all safe it's in your house where
you live your dad isn't going to bust
through the door
it's like it's it's great it's great but
like i never prayed so hard for like a
hand job in the back of the car in high
school you know what i mean like
i was like i was like finding god in
those moments you know i'm saying like
that's true yeah i remember having a
girlfriend giving me a [ __ ] in the
car yeah she had and she put her
sunglasses on i was like i'm in heaven
yeah it was like my sunglasses i don't
know i thought it was hot it was really
bright
she looked hot she's like can you put
these on
i didn't like they're like the big giant
ones maybe you should i'd like this one
some girls just don't like the eyes yeah
i don't i didn't like her eyes at all
but you looked at the lips and you're
like i was like those will do
no but yeah you know when you have that
moment like we have these like we have
living in the house we have home we hear
your girl
everything but it's like when it hits
you
you want to [ __ ] right there then then
when you're young it's like
if it hits you at the hotel if it hits
you when you walk around you're like
we need to [ __ ] now in high school it's
like
you want [ __ ] you're trying to find the
chance to [ __ ] any time yeah he's doing
that so as soon as the date
starts you're like on the escalator
going down the mall
every chance you're good hey you want
hot dog on a stick
you want applebee's like what do you
want you ever seen the couples walking
and they're like they're doing this
[ __ ] stupid dance and they're like
hip to hip and [ __ ] dude the best [ __ ]
too is i remember having
having an ex with parents right and then
like we'd hang out after school at her
place and then her mom be like okay i'm
gonna go pick up
your brother uh your brother don't do
anything while i'm gone
oh we're immediately naked like
literally 30 seconds after she leaves
like we're
and we're [ __ ] like already like it's
just that's you can't trust your kids
man you can't
why would they leave you alone i know
the parents do that
they say [ __ ] sex like like porn is
the
one thing that has advanced the internet
everything we got that we think we got
through whatever it's because of porn
like every from from vhs to dvd from dvd
to like really
everything on the internet is porn like
all of our advantages technological
advancements yeah it's because of people
by porn right yeah like the discovery of
like
4k was because the necessity to see high
level points
that makes a lot of sense concept is
like i mean i read those articles like
i know you're talking about porn is like
the one thing
for a society that we'd have to spend
zero dollars marketing
and it will forever be yup that's so
true zero dollars marketing we're all
gonna [ __ ] get
to hit that point this trend was
unbroken until
uh it was there was a battle between
blu-ray and hd dvd
back in the day and hd dvd was cool with
porn right so they
porn went into hd dvd and and blu-ray
obviously won
so that's the only time was yeah but
they're talking about
wi-fi [ __ ] 4g faster streaming
[ __ ] is because of [ __ ] porn what
about the
twitch streaming and all this [ __ ] right
now where people are um
donations and stuff that [ __ ] all came
from uh cam girl stuff i mean
this is chicks making good living on
only fans we
know bro i went to a antique shop
in vegas and then out there's a whole
playboy section and me and joe were like
what the [ __ ] so we're going back from
like the 90s 80s
70s the playboy's been around for a
while forever 50. but if you look at
even like
50s and 40s they were still hot what was
your favorite decade
it was kind of hot looking at 1940s and
i just yes yeah
yeah the pubic hair changed the pubic
hair
changes over the years i go to vintage i
go to vintage porn
sometimes because the girls are 100
natural and hot as [ __ ]
naturals are great and you know how
taboo it was so they're like that much
like
bad more bad they all have triangle tits
remember that why were their tits so
true just like
it was just like that back then they
were retro yeah
maybe they just didn't have implants at
that time so that was just more the
naturalness that was like
in the gravity was weird back oh yeah
yeah gravity changed
over time got heavier you know what's
because we lost so many nukes
that's nuclear testing yeah because it
was during the cold war exactly it was
very cold it was very cold so
their nipples were extremely hard got
hard that's correct
because it used to be really soft and
puffy and there's always like a lot of
like soft
like you know the photos are really like
fuzzy yeah yeah right and they're all
puffy and stuff
yeah it changed i don't know how to
change but
nuclear 40s 50s black and white i bought
some of them should come over and check
them out
that's how we used to do it see this is
how you this is how porn used to be in
the day
someone got it yep and then we all went
to go see it you passed it around
and you'd have to like pull the pages
apart because they're sticking with them
what's going on and like we knew these
these girls like intimately like
intimately
but now there's too much porn
you